♪ ♪ ♪
- Quand l'électricité est
partie, on s'est mis à entendre
un énorme bruit. C'est très,
très, très bruyant, les maisons
qui tombent dans le fond
d'un trou.
- On a perdu notre village.
On a perdu, t'sais, des amis.
- Elle était enceinte
de cinq mois. Elle attendait
un petit bébé. Annie, elle,
avait deux ans.
- L'être humain ne peut rien
contre la nature.
- Ginette Chavarie a attendu
50 ans avant de remettre
les pieds à Saint-Jean-Vianney.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Il n'y aura plus personne
en arrière pour le raconter si
on ne le fait pas aujourd'hui.
Il n'y a plus rien.
Plus rien. Plus rien.
- Elle avait 18 ans,
le soir du drame.
Un peu avant 23 heures,
elle dormait au sous-sol.
GINETTE CHAVARIE
- J'entends ma soeur et ma mère
crier en haut: "Monte en haut!
Dépêche-toi, pose pas
de questions!"
- Au même moment, une scène
similaire se déroule un peu
partout dans le village
de 1300 personnes.
Rolande Lavoie, la fille
du maire, a alors 23 ans.
Un coup de téléphone
alerte sa maisonnée.
ROLANDE LAVOIE
- M. Berthold Tremblay criait,
écoute : "Il y a des maisons qui
tombent! Il y a des personnes
à l'intérieur des maisons!"
Il criait, il criait.
- Les maisons toujours debout
n'ont plus d'électricité.
Chantale Arseneault n'avait
que 8 ans, à l'époque.
CHANTALE ARSENEAULT
- Moi, je savais qu'il fallait
se sauver. Je voulais apporter
mes petits vêtements de petite
fille que ma mère m'avait
achetés pas longtemps avant.
- Robert Bourgeois habitait
dans une maison un peu plus
loin, en amont. Les souvenirs
de cette soirée de ses 13 ans
sont intacts.
ROBERT BOURGEOIS
- J'ai vu tomber l'autobus de
l'Alcan. J'ai vu tomber l'autre
auto où la femme s'est retrouvée
sur le toit. De loin, là...
- Les citoyens doivent évacuer
le village en catastrophe.
- Tu ne savais pas si ça allait
partir en avant de toi,
même si t'avançais.
- À un moment donné, il arrête
une voiture, qui dit :
"Dépêchez-vous, allez-vous-en,
les maisons sont après tomber,
la maison à Bourgeois est
partie." Ça, c'était mon frère.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Le lendemain, 31 personnes
sont portées disparues.
La lumière du jour révèle
l'ampleur du drame qui s'est
déroulé sous leurs yeux.
Des maisons sombrent toujours
dans une épaisse coulée
d'argile.
- Le lendemain matin, quand on a
ouvert la radio avec mon amie,
là, ils nommaient toutes les
personnes qui étaient décédées.
Puis là, ils avaient nommé
Janette Landry. J'ai dit :
"Hein, Janette Landry?"
Là, j'ai... Là, j'ai pleuré.
- Robert Bourgeois n'a aucune
nouvelle de son frère, Gilles,
de sa conjointe Diane Arseneault
et de leur petite fille Annie,
deux ans.
Diane était la soeur
de Chantale Arseneault.
- Je ne sais pas de quelle façon
ils sont décédés. Je sais
que c'est une des premières
maisons qui a été engloutie
dans le glissement de terrain.
Faut pas que je pense. J'en
parle, j'en ai des frissons, là.
J'espère, Seigneur, qu'ils sont
partis très rapidement.
- Ginette Chavarie l'a échappé
belle. Cette maison à gauche,
au bout de la rue Stanley,
c'était celle de ses parents.
Après le sinistre, le
gouvernement de Robert Bourassa
a ordonné le déménagement
du village. Aujourd'hui,
il ne reste presque plus
rien à Saint-Jean-Vianney :
la nature a repris ses droits
dans les rues auparavant
peuplées de jeunes familles.
Mais 12 personnes n'ont
jamais été retrouvées.
- Ça me fait mal. Ça me fait
mal, parce que je les ressens.
Je ressens qu'ils sont là.
Je les ressens.
- Les noms des victimes
se retrouvent dans un parc
à Arvida.
On peut aussi apercevoir
les anciennes maisons déménagées
de Saint-Jean-Vianney dans
un quartier résidentiel de
l'arrondissement de Jonquière,
comme ici, sur la rue Dubuisson.
- C'est celle-là!
- Quelle ne fut pas la surprise,
pour Robert Bourgeois,
de découvrir, en revenant
dans le quartier, que les
propriétaires actuels
de son ancienne maison
sont eux aussi originaires
de Saint-Jean-Vianney.
L'espace d'une rencontre, les
anciens résidents se remémorent
leur jeunesse dans ce petit
village où tout était encore
à bâtir, mais où la nature
en a décidé autrement.
♪ ♪ ♪